you
[Music]
we have a finale Doshi Velez she's a
professor at Harvard University and has
done lots of really cool work on
probabilistic modeling sequential
decision-making interpret below machine
learning and with applications to
healthcare and I think she's gonna tell
us about some healthcare stuff cool to
be here to share some of the work that
we've been doing in our lab related to
the healthcare applications um in
reinforcement learning so um today's
talk it's gonna be like all of the
problems we work on that come from very
practical problems that we see and then
we go down and we try to improve like
our algorithms to deal with some of
these practical problems so I'll be
giving a range of things that we're
working on in the lab I also invite
interruptions very polite and quiet
crowd all day if you have questions
along the way that's fantastic I'd love
to hear them we don't have to get
through the slides we probably won't get
through all the slides anyway
so it's not your fault all right um so
what do we work on in my lab we work on
a couple of different application areas
we work on depression management we work
on critical care scenarios and ICU and
we also work on HIV couple of other
problems but this is like our main sort
of applications that we focus on and
today I'm gonna be focused on because
it's reinforcement learning I know
bandits are also part of reinforcement
learning but I'm gonna be focusing
specifically about problems that have
sequences of decisions so that's mostly
happening in the critical care space as
well as in the HIV management space so
first of all like just what makes the
healthcare scenario interesting or
challenging to work with many of these
things people are probably already
familiar with but I'm just gonna share a
few first of all the way we typically
work is our data comes in batches so we
go to a hospital we say can we have data
to help you analyze X and they give us a
big dump of data related to X right and
we're not really able to get you know
online updates and all of this sort of
thing and it takes a lot of work to get
even something like a very simple
prototype out
to the real world the other thing that's
really important to keep in mind is that
that database was designed probably for
billing purposes it wasn't defined to
make care you know better for patients
or make lives easier for doctors and so
lots of formants may be missing things
are going to be confounded and also the
intensive actions importantly are
missing so it may seem like sometimes
the doctor is behaving randomly but
maybe there's a variable that they're
very intentionally trying to to manage
that's just not recorded in any of the
data that we have available right so
that's the setting that we're dealing
with I mean finally success is not
always easy to quantify and we're doing
some reward learning work there was some
really great discussion about rewards
this morning so I'm not going to talk
about that here but the like learning
rewards is hard and doctors have a hard
time specifying like what is success
mean in different scenarios all right
but if you know this tie all these
troubles that we were just having a chat
during the coffee break you know I would
argue that it's important to still try
to do the best we can with the data that
we have right to ignore the fact that we
have these large databases would also be
kind of problematic right we want to try
to squeeze as much out as possible and
be aware of how much we can actually do
with the limitations that I point out
all right so here's the problem set up
and I'm really gonna spend any time on
it there's an agent there's a world
actions observations rewards let's move
into okay you've been hearing about this
all day let's move into how you might
tackle this problem so there's one class
of approaches that I would consider like
model based or value based approaches
and in these approaches you know we we
have some hidden state for example of
the patient that's evolving over time
and we try to fit a model of how that
state might be evolving what are the
observations that we're gonna get at was
the state evolution as we take different
drugs right so here's an example and you
know an example reward function and
we've trained the model we solve it
right so that's one class of approach
that we could take another class of
approach that people have thought about
is you know forget all of that
complicated our
all stuff just find another patient that
looks like you and just copy what worked
for them right and this is also like a
very reasonable story strategy you can
just think of this as a nonparametric
estimator and that seems to also be a
reasonable choice if you ask the doctors
as kind of what they're doing right
they're often thinking of it oh yeah I
saw someone similar I want to try a
similar action this time because it
worked for a patient before all right
and in getting the long-term effects
part of this is a little bit tricky so
one of the things that we did a couple
years ago now at this point was just to
notice that these two ideas that I just
told you about this parametric approach
fit the model you know fit the value
function versus this nonparametric just
find a clone in your data set approach
really how complimentary strings um and
that is if you happen to be lucky enough
to have a clone that's probably the best
world that you can live in right but if
you're not lucky enough to have a clone
in the data set it's probably best you
use a simplified model perhaps of
disease progression then to have to you
you know go to a clone clone that's not
really that similar to you right it's
not good to match to somebody that's far
away right um so that was the intuition
and then you can actualize that in the
following way um you can say that now
let's suppose we just have a mixture
right um our our clone type policy
suggests do action a our model fitted
policy suggests you action B we have
some statistics about the patient and
the data set like how they how that
patient relates to different patients in
the data set we can identify how close
they are for example to similar patients
and then output some sort of actual
action to do so we applied this strategy
the first place we applied it was into
the scenario of HIV management so this
was with the registry of about 33,000
patients um and observations you know
include cd4 viral loads etc and the goal
is to keep those viral loads low over a
long period of time five years in this
particular case and one thing I want to
point out is that there were a lot of
different drug
nations rights the action space was
fairly large and we did this sort of
thing and the the idea that I just
talked about is this policy mixture
policy that's the the second line from
the top let's say is gonna choose
depending on where you are either go
with the neighbor or go with the model
and dr is for doubly robust I'll get to
that point a few more moments obviously
we weren't checking on actual patients
we had to use an important sampling
based estimator decimate the the quality
of our proposed policy and in this
mixture model mixture policy we took
this idea one step further and said well
really the key ideas parametric versus
nonparametric so instead of mixing at
the level of a policy why don't we mix
at the level of a model and if a patient
is at a particular state right now and
for the next time step when we're trying
to predict what's gonna happen next
let's just see at that point in time do
you have a clone in the data set if you
do you know expect the next up set of
observations to be the observations that
would match your clone but if you're not
lucky enough to have a clone in the data
set just use the model and using that
model based approach which again is
mixing between this parametric and
non-parametric regressor results in a
slightly better performance not really
statistically significant they you know
looks like it could be if we had more
data all right so this is what we did um
and in fact that intuition that I told
you about turned out to be true
so we didn't build in a fact that said
you have to be X clothes to use the
parametric versus the nonparametric but
if we look at when these different
models are being used we see that when
the history is short
we often match right the kernel-based is
the find a clone approach which kind of
makes sense it's easier to match to a
short history whereas when the history
is long we tend to use the pom GP or the
model based approach and the kind of
analogously we noticed that the kernel
is used when the distance to your
neighbors is shorter and the pom DP is
used when it's longer again we didn't
tell the algorithm to do that we didn't
tend to an optimization but it kind of
makes sense which kind of makes you feel
good right so that at this point really
this is awesome
um let's just see what other problems we
can solve with this
approach um so we started looking at
substance management in the ICU and in
this specific case we are looking at
hypotension management or circulation
management so we want to make sure that
the patient's blood pressure stays in a
particular range while the rest of their
body is fighting the actual infection
associated with subsist and when we're
doing that there's two major axes and
take you can either increase your blood
pressure by up giving them vasopressors
which constrict the blood vessels or you
can increase their blood pressure by
just increasing the amount of fluid in
the body and both of them have pros and
cons right so now is the action space
that we were looking at and the goal was
to reduce 30-day mortality because
that's a long way off
we used a reward function that had to do
with like the log odds of 30-day
mortality and then when we actually
instantiated this approach we did it
slightly differently than before but the
idea remained the same the idea here is
that now we we still had to find a clone
policy that's your kernel and then we
instead of using a model we had an lsdm
to compress the history and then we
trained a ddq and on that and we placed
a little barrier to make sure I didn't
recommend crazy actions because as soon
as you start using things like ddq ends
you have no idea what's gonna come out
but anyway we did all of that and you do
the same again same rough process its
optimizing that function to choose
between these two you know very
intuitive choices to see what will come
out the best and so this is what we get
so what we find is that our approach
which is the the the columns off to the
side so all right the MOA columns
especially if you use the LS TM encoding
which is a recurrent encoding are doing
better in terms of this reward function
that we've created and we can compare to
the physician we can compare it to the
colonel and the dqn and just to make
this kind of intuitive we provide the
following plot so the first plot in the
second plot er the same is for the two
different
and what I'm showing here is that if you
take the action that the x-axis is the
difference between what we recommend
where the doctor did so zero means that
the doctor did what we recommended
negative means that the doctor did
something different positive means or
the doctor did something different and
on the y-axis you see mortality rate and
what you're noticing is that when the
doctor matches our action bit mortality
rate is lower and if it's off to the
side the mortality rate is overall
higher I'm seeing some nodding heads
right kind of makes sense so this is a
point where you know you're kind of
feeling good about yourself right I'd
show you some awesome numbers for the
HIV case I'm showing you some more
awesome numbers and more than awesome
numbers I have a plot which seems to
make a lot of sense right and makes you
feel good until we plotted this this is
what happens when you do no action or if
you do random actions and the plaid cook
about the same as it does when we
applied our optimal policy like if some
of you might have seen this before
because I've given this walk a couple
times they're versions of this talk a
couple of times and and some of you may
just be much more sophisticated about
reinforcement learning so you didn't
fall about for the initial plat in the
first place but I pointed this out just
to emphasize that this is tricky right
um knowing when to trust like an output
of these machine learning algorithms is
super hard right I still think that
there's value to the policies we found
and I'm going to explain to you why I'm
for the remainder basically of the talk
but you know this sort of stuff is kind
of very easy to get yourself misled in
the particular case of this you know if
you're wondering why the sort of stuff
happened the way we discretize the
actions was based on quantiles in the
data set so the for example for the
vasopressor dosage the initial actions
are quite close together right like
action one action to action three in
terms of absolute dose whereas the
further out action you know kind of
really action five is the biggest action
that's kind of a way but there's not
much
action going on there right um and so
what was really happening is that we're
really that this plot is really focused
only on the middle right and the middle
patients are all the healthy patients
the healthy patients are gonna survive
anyway I mean they're in the ICU right
you're sick but the more healthy ICU
patients are the ones who are more
likely survived are the ones who are
pretty much ending up here because
they're in the middle of the plot more
details we have in our archive post on
kind of why all of these stuff you know
why defects all right and that kind of
observation really was you know just to
start you've heard about some issues
earlier today but I'm just going to
reiterate when you apply these important
sampling based estimators you often get
quite high variances as you see here you
know our policy is up here it doesn't
look particularly it looks slightly
better but it's not clearly better than
the alternatives you also end up with
skewed data sets so what's going on here
that I'm trying to show is that if you
look at the weighted that once you apply
your important sampling what are the
trajectories that are retained right if
you think of important and sampling is
really taking a set of samples that you
keep and then throwing away the samples
that don't match you know roughly its
weighted but that's what's going on um
you know your your effective sample size
is quite small compared to the size of
the data set this is a log scale so
we've lost like two orders of magnitude
and worse than losing the two orders of
magnitude I would say is that the
sequence length in the data set varies
from 0 to 20 this is in for our bins so
0 to 80 hours the the sequence is
retained when we do our estimation are
quite short right because at some point
you know otherwise the importance
sampling weight goes to zero and we lose
the weight right and so we're really
looking at trajectories that are you
know in the 0 to 20 hour range and those
are very different population of
patients than are the overall population
of patients this is just the start right
um we could spend a long time
talking about all the issues with office
policy evaluation and bad stuff but
again just to emphasize these are the
sorts of things that can go wrong when
you're just kind of blindly turning the
crank on these sort of approaches and I
feel like it's really important for us
as kind of the experts in this area to
remember to educate people that we work
with about these sorts of problems
because these are not things that the
doctors are going to notice they're
gonna be like oh this is a shiny looking
number and they're not going to
necessarily view or you know even if
they've been educated about for example
sample sizes they might say oh your
tests had had you know three thousand
patients that sounds wonderful
right but the effective sample size was
quite a bit lower so just emphasizing
those as things that we probably want to
share with our colleagues when we're
working on these problems all right so
how can we increase confidence in these
results right so the the last several
years my lab has really been thinking
about different ways to holistically
think about how to again squeeze as much
out of these data as possible right that
was the original goal and so there is RL
right that's the part where that we kind
of really just know and love and it's
optimizing agents and sample efficient
ways with all sorts of cool estimation
techniques and function approximate errs
and all of that so that's kind of
sitting inside this dashed line and then
there's the world kind of outside all of
that of implicit stuff that goes on
so there's divine defining the reward
function which I'm not going to really
focus on in the representation which I'm
also not going to focus on coming in at
the inputs and then when it comes to
validation there's statistically about a
validation which I'm calling a policy
evaluation but there's also other things
that you might want to do and I'm just
calling that checks plus plus to see
like are we doing reasonable things with
our policy and I emphasize that just
because at some point you kind of you
run out if the statistics can only take
you so far right if there's a data set
of a certain size and there's a policy
that you're trying to check you know the
confidence intervals are just going to
overlap
and there's nothing you can do about
that and what do you do when you hit
that particular scenario in your data
alright so let me talk a little bit now
about off policy evaluation we've heard
about some of these things a little bit
earlier today and I'm just gonna share
highlights from a couple of things that
we're working on in the lab toward this
that are again inspired by things that
we believe would be helpful in the
particular types of applications that
we're working on all right so a policy
evaluation just as a quick definition
again I think most people in the room
are are pretty familiar with this you
know we're collecting data from the
clinicians we want to estimate the value
of a policy that is under some proposed
thing like the things that I talked to
you about before right like what if we
use this mixture based model that seems
quite sensible but you know how well
will it perform right so that would be
our PI II um and there's three major
kinds of approaches right just kind of
like in how in RL we kind of split
between like models values and policies
we have is type approaches typically
high variance we have model based
methods which are typically high bias
value based methods which can also
suffer from high bias and we've been
doing work on the the first two at the
moment and some ongoing work on the
third category I'm just gonna share a
couple of stories from what we've been
working on so when it comes to important
sampling as I mentioned the big issue is
that at some point let's say our
evaluation policy doesn't want to do the
things that the clinician actually did
so we have a sequence of decisions and
we're going along in the sequence at
some point especially if PI II is
deterministic probability of the
clinician action given our state under
our proposed policy is going to be zero
and at that point this weight goes to
zero right and even if you're using a
stepwise estimator you still lose the
entire end of the trajectory right and
if you care about something that happens
further in the future this is obviously
a problem
so one way we can ameliorate this issue
that we've been looking at is what if we
can stitch trajectories that we were
going to throw out so what if you had
you know here's your desired sequence so
you have four states I mean in each of
those states you were hoping to take
this red action that that takes you to
the right so you that's your desired
sequence but in real life
here's your batch of data and you never
actually did that you you have a example
of data that went to the right twice and
then went down you have an example that
goes through right once goes down and
goes to right twice again and
importantly the states still match up
right I'm like this button in this
little toy example is not changing your
transition but it's something else
that's providing rewards so in this
particular case um you might think okay
I have to throw these out or you know
here again if you're doing a per
decision you would say well I can only
keep the first two time steps of the
first one and the first time step of the
second one but what if you could take
the two that you were going to
effectively throw out and stitch them
together right and again in this toy
example I can do that because the states
align exactly right so we work this out
in the kind of just all the maths of it
in the tabular case you end up with some
subtleties and how you now have to
adjust and calculate importance weights
so in the tabular case and in the end
we're working on it for the continuous
case but I'll show you just a labor of
the example that we get so you what
actually before I do this um so what is
this intuitively doing um and why do we
kind of like this as an approach so what
this isn't to Italy doing is its
increasing the size of the the data the
number of trajectories that you can use
for any downstream thing so if whether
you're going to apply you know your wdr
your PW PD is whatever it is right
whatever is based technique that you're
going to apply you can apply it with
this rejiggered dataset so the nice
thing is is that as new and fancy
technique
come out in that space we're not
preventing you from using any of those
right this isn't an estimation method
per se it's a method for increasing the
amount of data that you can use for your
estimation method and so what we show on
some simple examples is that if you have
estimation methods on the bottom axis is
episodes as you gather more episodes the
error goes down and as the error is
going down the dashed lines show the
benefit of using our approach on top of
you know standard is Wis PD wdr right so
in all of these cases it's a standard
method but we're just increasing the
amount of the size of the data that you
have available so you get a better
estimate all right so so that was a way
of you know augmenting any kind of
important sampling based approach with
more data that so you don't have any any
trajectory based importance sampling
based approach with more data so that
was one example of work that we've done
and now I'll tell you a little bit about
some model-based work that we're also
doing all right so here we are and and
this one I think is super cool
because we're using mixtures again so
that intuition before about oh hey you
know what if we had like this parametric
thing where we jump from place to place
or we build a model and we switched
between the two now what if we apply
that idea but now for evaluation because
if we think about it in the evaluation
setting we have exactly the same sort of
question that we had in the optimization
setting right when we're over here our
evaluation policies days take action
a-and if you're lucky enough to have a
copy of action a taken in that state in
your data set then why not use it right
take that tuple and continue to build
your trajectory off of that but if
you're not lucky enough maybe you fall
back on a parametric model all right so
that's intuition number one intuition
number two is the following um I might
want to make sure that as I'm doing this
I am trying to stay in areas that are
well modeled right so let's suppose that
I have a region that's not very well
modeled that's the one in yellow and I
have a region that's well modeled that's
the one in blue and if I have this sort
of scenario and now I have two forms of
simulators right and where the two
simulators again could be that
parametric and non-parametric prop model
that's how we usually end up
instantiating it in our case but really
this is general right so you could have
K you know approximate models that's
that part is it doesn't have to be
parametric and non-parametric
but let's say you have your models those
are the lines and here is what really
happens in real life the agent if it
executes the policy it's gonna follow
this green line across this particular
region and you have two choices of which
model to use at the first time step two
guess where that agent is going to end
up so if you use the the black model um
you're going to get something that's
closer to the Green Dot which is great
right is it's more accurate it's more
accurate than the dashed line but by
going into this yellow region you know
that you might do poorly later on in
terms of evaluating you know the what
the effect of different actions right
because we're in a model-based scenario
we're gonna simulate out we're gonna do
rollouts and what could happen is that
once you reach here um you kind of just
go off the rails right because this is
the poorly modeled region you're trying
to estimate the quality of this policy
that goes through a poorly model region
so maybe the better thing to do if you
just care about the the error is to take
a hit the first time and then stick to
the well modeled area if I kind of stay
close to the that now you're now your
fault you're following the trajectory
assuming that the first step actually
took you here rather than over
here so this is its own little RL
problem which is kind of cute right now
we're using reinforcement learning to
choose which model so the action space
is the which model to choose and the
reward function is the mean square error
of the estimate of the policy so we're
looking at different forms you know
choosing between models to do our
rollouts and the different models have
different accuracies in different places
so what kind of more formally how do we
do that and too much time on this we
have a bound on the quality so this is
our error that we're trying to manage it
depends on the error from state
estimation and reward estimation the key
term that I'll point out is that you
have this this Lipschitz constant of the
transition which kind of is a key thing
that will cause things to blow up as you
crew the biggest errors and we can do
that Lipschitz constant estimation both
as a parametric and non-parametric case
by just simulating or looking for nearby
examples so again there's some
estimation and approximations involved
but this are you know if this thing is
computable based on once you make a
couple of approximations so we can
compute our reward function the action
space is relatively simple because they
were just choosing between two different
options so here's a here's a toy example
but an actual computed toy example of
what happens when we do this so in this
case there's two actions there's one
action that takes you straight across
and there's one action that takes you
off diagonally so there's two different
actions and we ended up collecting data
only two trajectories that end up doing
just one action or the other so there's
one trajectory that does this and
another trajectory that goes up so
that's our data and now um you know just
to for a sake of illustration let's
suppose that I fit a parametric model
the
doesn't know the difference between the
two actions right so I fitted model with
all the data and I asked it to predict
next date given current state and
because of that I'm gonna conflate these
two actions together so my parent metric
model stays regardless of what action
you do you are always gonna go up at an
angle an angle that is slightly less you
know is in between these two that make
sense any questions all right so that's
the set up for this little toy example
and now here is what the evaluation
policy wants to do it wants to go up one
step go across and then go up again and
I want to get something close to that
policy based on my parametric model and
by being able to use the data the right
samples from the data which is my
nonparametric model so what happens if
I'm kind of greedy well if I'm greeting
I'm like oh okay
the first thing that our evaluation
policy did was go up right diagonally up
so I'm going to just take a sample from
my data because my data does add I'm
gonna copy that and then you reach a
point where you're like huh okay now my
model says go to the side and I have the
choice between sticking with my with my
data that doesn't really seem to and and
I can also say my parametric model does
this and I choose my parametric model
because it has less air right at this
point if I'm over here then my two
choices I'm sorry to the people on the
other side I wish there was like a way
to like clone myself I walk back and
forth so here they are over here um
this is closer and kind of every step of
the way it's gonna be better to choose
the parametric model and so here's a
trajectory this is your gonna be your
guest this green line is gonna be your
guess for the purple line okay I'll go
to the other side to give the the better
example okay so that's them something
going wrong right is there a better
solution well a better solution would be
to say you know what I'm going to use my
parametric model first even though it
accrues a little bit of error because
then after that I can use all of this
data but kind of
roughly follows the purple line right
not exactly but it stays closed and then
once the purple line starts going up I
go back to my parametric model and this
blue line over here which was planning
ahead for the areas that it's gonna
accrue ends up looking closer to the
purple line than the green one does so
that's the the key idea in this approach
so we're taking that same intuition from
the beginning of the talk about how can
we mix kind of clones versus models but
now really formalizing it in a way that
we can use it for off policy evaluation
so that's the intuition of like why this
might work and how it might work
you know why planning is actually
important and it works on you know a
real task so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm just you know at close time is I'm
going to quickly go through like we've
done other work on model based stuff
I'll you know if you're curious I'm
happy to chat about it at some other
point I want to talk a little bit about
validation and skip to a couple of
things that we're doing there that I'm
really excited about
so the off policy evaluation even with
all the stuff that we're developing
again it's gonna run into some hard
statistical limits in our particular
case you know the doctors are being able
to observe stuff about the patient that
we cannot observe so we know that
there's major missing confounders in the
data set but at the same time there's a
lot of data that is in the data set and
the doctors are not capable of looking
at all the data about a patient
certainly not capable of comparing all
that data about a patient to all the
other patients in the database right so
there is value that we can provide um
but we also have to be kind of very
aware that there's gonna be some major
limitations and the many of the
assumptions that are required also for
off policy evaluation are not
necessarily gonna be met right so even
if we have a method that has nice
guarantees if your state space as well
defined uh cetera etc it's not going to
hold you know in in our real
applications so what can we do really
how can we feel good
about policies that kind of have
reasonable numbers but we're just not
sure what you know about all of our
assumptions so I'm going to go quickly
through some of this
so we've we do simply we make sure that
our results reproduce across sites
that's kind of important we check
sensitivity to all sorts of modeling
assumptions if we're using like
something that requires like a covariant
like wdr we also talked a lot with the
experts you know we compare against
standard of care we ask clinicians do
these policies make sense we gather
annotations these are somewhat basic
things that one might want to do and the
the thing that I'm going to spend the
last couple minutes talking about and in
terms of like deep dive into you it's
like well when we're asking the doctors
like what's the best way to actually ask
them if something makes sense so the the
the numbers sitting up here on this
slide we gave them examples right we
gave them a patient we gave them a
recommendation we said does this
recommendation make sense we got like an
agreed disagree a partially disagree but
that's a kind of very limited way of
showing doctors what the agent will do
and in particular a piece that was
missing is that how do we select those
patients right how do we know how can we
feel good about you know this patient
selection this group was was good enough
right because if the the clinician said
that this this group it looks great
would we feel good about going forward
with this policy probably not right well
we are depending on how we chose them
maybe not I mean if they said it made no
sense then we would know we have to go
back to the drawing board but a positive
result doesn't necessarily indicate that
we have a good policy so there's a
question of how to validate an entire
policy given only some samples so that's
very little detour and another area that
we've been working in is how can we best
communicate a treatment policy to a
clinical expert so we formalize it in
the following setting we're gonna
present the expert with some state
action pairs right in this particular
state the agent does this the expert now
is going to be given a new state s Prime
and we ask them what action is gonna
happen
this state s Prime and if they can guess
it then we can be like you can feel good
we can be like okay the expert has a
good sense of how this agent is going to
behave and then we're gonna trust the
expert to tell us whether the agent is
reasonable right but if we can only do
that if the agent can do a great job of
kind of simulating what the agent will
do so our goal the thing that we have
control over is that training set right
the teaching set that we give to the
expert for them to be able to recover
back the entire policy so here's an
example where here is a grid world and
we the arrows that are filled in are the
examples of state action pairs and then
the tasks for example would be for those
queries that are circled in black what
are the actions that you know the thing
that the agent is gonna take right now
the optimal action but what is the
action that the agents gonna take any
guesses people have any hypotheses about
what's going on down in green okay
anyone else people are too tired okay go
right in the yellow okay okay I see okay
in general can you summarize though okay
down in green you have no idea okay
so there's there's two forms of things
that people often do with these tasks
which have words that you know and the
first word you know so if so if the
policy was like down in green that's
like an imitation type policy right or
like I think that this often happens in
this state and the other thing could be
like it looks like they're trying to go
to blue that's an inverse reinforcement
learning so we don't know what the
people are actually doing are they doing
IRL or are they doing il and the
implications would be different for this
sort of state action pairs that we want
to present so in this case um you know
many times people end up doing more like
inverse reinforcement learning they
think that there's a goal that people
are trying to get to whereas if we give
them examples that look like the
following
so in this particular case where you
know
this is different treatments and
different biomarkers people like I have
haven't the foggiest what's going on you
know what happens in this state
I just coffee right I do this to Frey I
look at that one I try to find a copy of
this over here I'm an imitation learner
for this particular type of data set and
what we showed is that it's really
important to know what people are going
to do well wait first of all yes so
quantitatively we noticed a difference
so we asked people so this is a Turk
study we asked people afterwards after
they did the experiment to tell us like
what their thought process was and then
we went through all of those things and
tried to code them into something that
looks like Ilir l or can't tell so the
gray is like we couldn't tell from their
description exactly what they were doing
so in HIV case this one over here people
were just like okay we copied right that
was clearly imitation learning in the
grid world more often people were
describing something that looked more
like with the agent is trying to get to
a goal I understand now and those
differences mattered in the following
sense so now we could imagine that I
create a summary assuming that you are
an imitation learner right and then I
give you that example or I create a
summary assuming that you're a inverse
reinforcement learning learner and
that's a different form of summary that
I'm going to give you how would you
perform if you assume that the the the
extraction method you know I should be
using IRL or IO so the dashed lines show
how you would expect performance to be
and what the important thing to notice
is that you know in the different
domains you know there's a swap there's
not a clear better method and so it's
important to match um and we also notice
that in the different domains so if we
match what people did remember people
were mostly imitation learners in the
HIV domain if we create the sample
knowing that they're gonna do imitation
learning they do better then if we
create the sample assuming that they're
gonna do
so this is kind of an important piece of
information like if we're going to be
presenting examples having the right
model of the human cognition of how
they're going to extrapolate from the
models is very important this is kind of
obvious but it we did the actual study
to show that this is important and when
we think about how to present examples
to the doctors we kind of want to
understand what these knots and bolts
look like alright so what I'm gonna do
is I'm just going to finish up one other
thing that we have that we're working on
is we want also if things are
statistically indistinguishable we want
to offer options so if we have a couple
of different policies we want to be able
to say that some of the policies are
clearly bad like the ones in gray the
other ones might be reasonable and we've
applied this again to like the
hypotension management tasks in the ICU
I won't go into detail on that because I
want to save time for a couple of
questions okay so going forward so are L
in the health space I think is a really
interesting area um I was working on our
L applied to nothing during my PhD and
now that I'm working on these health
applications I feel like I'm working on
very different questions but they're all
very satisfying right there's all sorts
of really interesting technical
questions that come up and when you're
working with a real domain you care a
lot about how things are gonna work and
in terms of things to keep in mind you
know let's think holistically about how
are L performs in the real world and
keep in mind that usually is a human
agent system that's making the choices
so all of our work the way we think
about it is that our agent is going to
be providing information and
recommendations to a human who has
additional information they're going to
combine those together to make final
choice right so it's important to think
about how the system is going to behave
in the real context and also we have to
be careful with the analyses right like
that first example where I showed you
where you know you can just run a bunch
of numbers things can look totally
peachy and then you're kind of like way
the number is me nothing that happens
and we have to make sure we were aware
of that that we take care of that but
let's not also make that such that we
don't think about messy problems that
a lot of potential impact and to just
two quotes that I really like you know
going back to comic books actually you
know so we have with great power comes
with great responsibility right we have
to be careful but in the same time
perfect is the enemy of the good right
and if we stick with the status quo then
that's also a problem right when there's
better solutions that are potentially
out there so I'll leave it at that and
take any questions thank you so we have
time for a couple questions
so I have one question happen again okay
so I guess I'm curious about like the
implications of work you have on people
wanting to do imitation learning I'm
kind of curious about like if that given
that that's what people want to do what
well it depends scenario dependent I
think that's what we found and I think
so one thing that we didn't do here this
was an entirely a Turk study it wasn't
with doctors so my hypothesis is that if
you kind of can understand the domain
you will probably use IRL okay that
you're like oh you're doing that because
you're trying to get to this goal um
whereas if you're not super familiar
with the domain you will probably just
imitate um you know somebody says you
know step to the left okay I'm just
gonna stop soon you know like I have no
idea why somebody said that every why
somebody did that um and and so if we
gave some of these examples to the
doctors like the HIV example they may
actually be doing IRL and that's
something we just the study made
basically the important part of the
study was that if we make the wrong
assumption we actually do get worse
quality because it could have been that
maybe the assumptions don't matter right
like people are kind of to somehow grow
busts or whatever samples you give them
which could have which could have come
out so a related question going forward
how would you think about like doing
this for a new task with doctors say
like yeah so one thing actually we
discovered after this study is that
we're still really interested in
extensions of this and how to do this
with doctors um but one thing that came
out of more discussion as we've been
talking to the clinicians is that even
though they often think in terms of
clones right they think in terms of data
points I met this other patient five
years ago and this thing happened when
they communicate with each other they
still have to communicate in the
language of features right does that
make sense so like if I tell you about
this patient five years ago it's not in
your head I have to see that patient I
saw five years ago who was you know over
seventy years old and had you know
broken hip and
and I'm exciting this patient to you but
I'm describing it to you in terms of
features and so seeing how those that
communication works we think that that
might be actually the key to describing
a policy is like looking at the features
of the language of the communication
that they're already using and then
putting the policy into those terms and
so that's kind of where our current work
is headed so just following up on that
the parametric nonparametric split that
you talked about there might be some
ways to bridge it so local learning is
the one that comes to mind where you
train a parametric model on the K
nearest neighbors weighted appropriately
and some of the interpret ability
methods like Lyman particular do you
really want to Train separate models
would you just build some model that
works the best I mean that the mixture
stuff and I think that I mean on people
use all kinds of ensemble anxiety in
tuition my guess is that there's always
gonna be some cases where you want to do
some kind of ensemble and we could have
come up with intelligent ways to do that
I'm from an interpretability perspective
I see that as kind of different like I'm
not sure so so lime does these local
perturbations I think it's really
important to understand that the Delta
of the perturbation like that that's
maybe a longer discussion of like how to
do interpretability for policies or
classifiers
okay and so that's it I just want to
wrap up with a couple thank-yous and
shout outs so first of all thanks to all
the speakers this event would not have
been interesting without them so let's
let's give them another round of
applause
[Applause]
second of all thanks to all of our
support staff we have some people from
outreach gen VN Sheikh is sitting
outside Liz teason is in Redmond and
Jessica I guess is in Montreal they
really made all this very seamless for
myself and Hal
thanks to our videographer our social
media people our photographer I don't
know where she went oh let's give a damn
all around replies again this is art of
making the event and then I want to
thank Hal my co-conspirator and helping
me put this together it was a very fun
and trying do it again next year
and lastly thanks to all of you for
coming this is part of what makes the
event really fun to see everyone and I
hope you all it a great time anything
else okay thanks
[Applause]